White lives matter tell me your take on
Kanye's t-shirt okay
a white man owns the slogan black lives
matter
what if Kanye owns the slogan why lives
matter can I break some news right now
okay my best friend in the entire world
is a black man Ramses owns White lives
matter
is he linked with Kanye no oh well I
don't know
Connie don't own it but a black man does
a black man owns White lives matter
right now so Kanye's promoting black
businesses yeah I mean
Kanye knew that because he just bought
the phone now
what if he did know you don't think it's
a little like a like uh
I'm not saying I agree right I'm just
saying instead of
us all bashed let's see what's the
madness behind it like does he own this
slogan I know Candace Owens has a
documentary coming out about all the
money black lives matter stole from
people is this merch for that
so my thing is is a couple of things can
be right one black lives matter the
organization yes clearly [ __ ] some
[ __ ] yes right yes I donated I also
am glad I talked to Killer Mike when all
that was happening he told me who to
give money to and I gave it to like not
like I gave it a lot of our money went
to Joe Biden
whoever it went yeah so that's true
right yes the [ __ ] Foundation is
obviously corrupt yes
what also is true is the term black
lives matter is factual and the reason
why it became a thing was because it is
pretty evident that in the United States
black lives have never been valued in
the same way White lives have been
valued right so I think in in the spawn
of like black lives matter becoming this
movement that a lot of old white people
associated with riots and violence and
[ __ ] for sure
White lives matter became the opposite
or all lives matter became like the
super like crazy
redneck Trump Mega hat wearing ass thing
to say so it so the term White lives
matter is also true White lives matter
sure they do yes all lives matter all
lives of course all lives but it's not
about all lives or what I just think
that that when you say White lives
matter it like it it it's not just the
term like when Kanye said on Tucker
Carlson I said it because it's true like
he's not wrong but at the same time like
the symbolism of wearing that I think
that's where it gets
combative because it's like
exactly what you're saying it comes
across as you're going against just to
do it well yeah just stir it always yeah
but I don't think at the level Kanye's
at
and you know I could be wrong that he
would just do that to do that yeah I
think there's definitely some type of
method behind it and there's something
coming behind I don't know what it is
but what I'm going to say is until I
fully know I'm not just going to develop
an opinion and just be like oh [ __ ]
Kanye because he wore a white lives
matter I want to see what's the method
behind it now if it's solely him just
being a dick you know what I mean and
want to be combative then I'm not for
that but if it is something behind it to
where he's trying to change a narrative
let's see how it passes and I understood
like his reasoning for wearing the Trump
hat because I I think he said I didn't
get that so I understood it because he
essentially was saying
you don't have to like the Democratic
party is taking advantage of the black
vote forever for sure the whole reason
why Joe Biden is the president is
because I think it was the South
Carolina has anybody seen Kamala Harris
she's from your city right has anybody
seen her
I don't know man have you ever seen her
she's shall she she got I haven't seen
her since she was yes Joe we've did it
we did it Joe I haven't seen her I'd
like to see you come on let's come
outside but I think him wearing the Maga
hat was a point to be made that hey
we're not automatic like think freely
think for yourself just because you're
black but that's Kanye yeah that's Kanye
I think sometimes
he's so much of a Ford dinker right it
gets the message gets lost because of
the way it's communicated at times
um I don't think he means any harm I
think he's a disrupter right I think
he's a creative genius
um I just think sometimes he
communicates
his message in a confusing way to
certain people but I don't think we
should bash him for it I think we should
hear him out see how it plays out see
what happens
and if we don't agree we don't agree you
know if you do agree cool if not move on
that's uh have you ever like heard of
Kanye [ __ ] with your [ __ ] at all or I
worked with Kanye you've worked with him
yeah I worked on donda for four days in
the Mercedes-Benz Stadium wow what was
the best experiences of My Life
um that's why I said I can't just bash
them because you've been around him you
know him it's it's something to it yeah
like he's always thinking forward that's
when he was living there right yeah yeah
he was there for Ford well he was there
for like a month but I was there for
four days and uh I'd watch him write a
song go in another room do a Melody go
in another room and design a building go
in the cafeteria and have a meeting with
Balenciaga about what the fashion show
needs to look like in 2025 yeah go to
rehearsals go to choreography go back in
the room and tell them joints to make a
beat take a certain part of that beat
and send it to 88 keys like he's he's
just a creative guy you know so it's
like I can't being around somebody like
that is hard to just say they're coming
from a place of malice that's fair you
know you kind of gotta see it all the
way through because you might not have
the full information yeah so I gotta
wait and see I don't I don't know I
can't just make an opinion